taking lyrics you've got that that
little refrain the sugar my right
thinking that's not correct so I got I
got schooled very early on in the I had
written this little motif that repeats
throughout the show
it's like Jenna goes into her baking
reverie and so I thought oh how sweet
sugar butter flour so that repeats over
and over again and then an expert pie
Baker pulled me aside and was like you
know there's no sugar it's salt give me
back the tickets to the show that is
rude Jew who'd know that Emma's husband
Greg who was a champion Baker yes it
won't only one celebrity bake-off yeah
that's posh it was posh but no you
nearly ruined it for him they were they
were given this challenge I mean it's
extraordinary what they're asked to do
bake yourself in biscuits make a biscuit
version of yourself so he created
himself and he decided he'd make a sort
of pancake thing that was a kilt and so
you made a kind of structure which was
him
biscuit legs and there's and then this
kilt and then more of him up above and
leaves and trees and things and it was
all base of Salvador Dali meets you know
anyway I came in one night and drink had
been taken and I walked in and I saw the
structure and I didn't really take it in
and but then I saw the kilt and it
looked good it looked good enough to eat
so I
yeah exactly he came down the next
morning and it was just who yes
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
you